domingo clave en alemania lección clave
en alemania en la que no solamente se
está discutiendo ampliamente el legado
político de la canciller angela merkel
tras 16 años en el poder sino en el que
también está en juego el futuro político
del país y ese es un futuro que podría
tardar meses en conocer si tiene que ver
todo esto con el sistema político del
país pues los votantes aquí en alemania
no eligen directamente a su canciller lo
que eligen es a los diferentes partidos
que formarán parte del parlamento con
base en la fuerza política de los
diferentes partidos los líderes se
reunirán para tratar de formar acuerdos
de buscar ese gobierno de coalición que
en últimas es el que determinará el
rumbo político del país en los próximos
cuatro años y esa búsqueda de consensos
puede demorarse mucho tiempo en 2017 en
las últimas elecciones
angela merkel y su bloque conservador
tardaron cinco meses en buscar ese
acuerdo de coalición y los expertos
aseguran que como el país está tan
polarizado esta vez esa búsqueda de un
de coalición también podría demorarse
bastante tiempo tras las elecciones de
este domingo